okay for people listening watching on a
live stream
okay people on the live stream this is
another episode of our continuing series
of internal design of view meetings
about features for the upcoming versions
of Wathan language today's we're going
to actually do several of these today
this first one is about a fairly
systems-level thing HTTP import and
export so without further ado let's get
down to business here all right so this
is about importing walk files is that
correct
what is it alone yes for the three
formats here there's work which most of
the design questions we have resolved
around work and then there's also HTTP
response and request which I are pretty
straightforward so wait a minute we
already have HTTP response and it should
be requested so what would what's being
chained oh I see the import and export
all those yes yes okay so in other words
export strings are just to understand
this this is to actually take an HTTP
request that has been produced from for
example generate HTTP request is that
right so we don't have generate HP
request we have generate HT response yes
for the response exporter and importer
yes you could you could Ivan example
that below under the HTTP responses how
would you get a nation but this HTTP
request is I I don't recall what let me
go yeah the h3 requests like object is
also the the function is the same as the
constructor for that object and so if
you just type in issue your question you
get back that that summary box as the
object okay but it defaults to this
content type of what oh yeah I mean
because because I didn't specify in the
simple example I have right there I
didn't specify anything and so yes I
believe HTV request defaults to that
content type if you don't specify you
can also specify it in the arguments to
HV requests why are we default into iso
8859-1 I mean that's iso latin-1
character set does anybody have any idea
why would default into that I
the reason we default to that one is
because that's the least likely - to
break something if you have this is so
exact for example if you have like bytes
a byte sequence in there that is for
some character encoding like utf-8 or
something like that but we don't know if
it's utf-8 iso latin will preserve those
bytes whereas if you try and use ASCII
or something like that
those bytes will just become you know
like okay you'll lose the data you know
I understand the interpretation of the
bytes will be wrong because it has
nothing to do with it it's nothing I
sell out in one but it won't actually
smoosh the bytes it won't yeah you won't
lose those bytes when use ISO up that
one okay all right so let's see where do
we where do we start here so we're going
looking at HTTP request and the
exporting of HTTP request that looks
fine to me
um do I should I be looking at the
documentation of the fire there's a
format page for him what I should be I
just updated I just updated like like
when this meeting started I updated okay
um however this is not working this this
is dead
um let me bring up let me bring it up
just in 11 - ah let's see if this works
you know it does so it's continuing to
be dead in the X kernel um okay so get
format page I want HTTP request all
right this seems pretty uncontroversial
um it's there more to be written here I
mean it's just for you to review and if
it looks good we can move on it's you
know the other day there's no special
options or and what is the mind support
how does the mime support work so there
isn't a mime type for HP request however
the body of a request could have a mime
type in these time
but is that is that encoded in the HTTP
request or is that encoded is that
energy so if you look at so tonight it's
the content alright if you set the
content type option in the example I
have over there to utf-8 or something
you'll see another line show up that
says content type you know
utf-8 they're exactly what it is okay
and why we should use export string here
by the way in this example
export string yeah I mean don't put in a
file I mean my gosh I'm just show the
string explicitly okay okay so I mean
the examples that you give here look
like the right examples to give here it
seems right to me
okay use it with a socket to make an
HTTP request this should also be in the
examples right string to the socket of
the now is that right a string all right
a byte array if you want to do write a
byte array you could use binary right
sock export byte array that that also
works fine okay but this is writing that
okay what is this this is just a little
bit of a key code I have because there's
a bug with the socket reading and read
string should just work however it's
there's a bogan X for Nolan it's not
working so this works around that book
but okay so I mean the it would normally
be read string on the socket it's not
correct that's all it would be read
string of the socket and then you just
do a port strain of that so if I did
import byte array here we have import
byte array don't we yep so if I did
import byte array I wouldn't need to do
the byte array to string correct yes
okay I just included by the rate of
string to show show what that looks like
if you wanted to see
it's rather unwieldy you know it's our
website right yeah exactly
okay
we probably should have a sample website
that we can use for these examples that
is that has much more trivial HTML on it
yeah example data at Wolfram comm we
could have you know I mean that there is
like the there's a page that's just loop
all the pages it's just a listing of all
50 states it's like example data dot
Wolfram calm slash I think I think if
this / 50 states dot txt let me find
that but I think that would be a good we
can add any other thing there I mean if
you know those are because I see this I
I mean you can use this if you want to
or you could just have something which
is even more trivial than that that just
says you know this is an example or
something that's what I would do I mean
I just don't think you should have any
any meaningful content there this is
already a long list that will kind of
snarl up pay and look example um okay
let's keep going
do you want to and future iced tea or do
you want to wait a ton future Eisinger
you cannot fix ur eyes this go ahead you
can unlock it I'm not gonna go because I
mean there's a bunch of crud here that I
you know needs to be removed
ya want me to do the honors of
emphasizing it no I can do it on this
okay finally usually your day I know I
know I know but I feel like this one
needs it's examples change and all that
kind of thing okay HTTP response let's
take a look at this why are you doing a
quiet on that HTTP response again
external is I mean you can remove the
quiet than you get a giant message do it
still works and the message do I has
been reported it should be fixed soon
but if you guessed it works they're just
random messages
okay export string bad request happens
because that wasn't a number right yeah
so if you change out to a number then
you should get meaningful HTTP response
um okay fine okay looks good don't see a
problem with any of this I mean I let me
just try it just for fun
oh come on
yeah I'm not actually sure whether
that's not working I guess I didn't
actually try the correct case
well I don't think it's I think it
requires a string right
okay I mean this would be what what
happens if I just say generate HTTP
response of something completely trivial
um yeah I mean yeah
delayed of now okay there I've got
something meaningful well we need to
find out what happened to that I I don't
know I'm not aware of that syntax for
generate HTTP response with the query in
there
yeah that's the second link to our form
I thought it would actually be
GDP
response I mean an HTTP request wrapper
in there if you understand what I'm
saying yes I think it should be I filed
the bug because it does if you put h3
request as the second argument it
actually doesn't work it it fails all
right fine fine okay okay so here now
we've got that HT response 201 earth is
all this junk
what is all that stuff that's just the
HTML so you see the middle right there
begin page content that's just all the
HTML that was generated just for that
string if you did I think delayed
I think delay takes a format argument in
which case you could specify you know
you just want like raw text instead of
the full yeah so if you do delayed comma
yeah okay I get it
that's nice yep okay um okay all right
let's continue okay work yep okay so
we'll have a file for for work in in the
example data files this is just a one
that's run on you know the archive.org
site that returns the data set like this
okay default thing is to return a data
set from the wolf oh yes yeah yeah
there's a formula page for work so you
can open that up too and the default
element is its data which contains a few
specific headers that that we recognize
and and are kind of required to be there
such as the work version the URL the
date the content type the payload I
think there's one other one if you
scroll over to the side
and maybe it's just payload yep record
ID yeah which is kind of like a UUID fur
for work stuff so those are the specific
ones that if you just get data you know
the default element it gives you a
dataset with all this stuff and the
payload can can vary depending upon
which you know what type of thing is in
each each element of the work file so
for example some of those ellipses are
HTTP requests and responses click on
that you can see the it's not a live hit
but I made it alive now yes and some of
them are also just like metadata that
are generated with the work what did I
just get I'm sorry I'm confused here
I just oh I see there's that I jumped up
there okay that's that's one of the
payloads okay so I see so the walk file
contains various things that happen
during the operational web crawler
exactly these are so these are this is
the URL and this one apparently didn't
have a URL because that is simply a
thing that is describing the version
number of the walk program or something
like this okay if you click on the
payload for that one it'll just tell you
you know hey we're using this software
to run the work we're running it on this
date against this website you know like
yeah and so that so that element in the
work file is just like metadata about
here's how I ran the crawl all the other
things are you know actually crawl
things okay okay default data set with
specific headers we should talk about
that
um raw data all headers
understand that interpretation so if I
say this , headers the difference is in
how interpreted it is like dates are
interpreted or their rawest strings so
headers do any interpretation of the
values it'll just extract certain
specific ones and give you back the
string as it was found in the file
whereas data will interpret stuff and to
say for example a date object why is it
called hennas why is this called headers
I made sense to me I guess maybe it
doesn't make sense well explain it so so
I mean I think he was that you know the
default thing that's data that's what
you want normal to work with that's your
data set and then if you go down to the
next kind of level down which is raw
data that's all the stuff we curate and
say you know here's a specific version
here's the work type etc but then here's
all the other random headers that might
be there right because there's no like
listing of headers that could be any
random thing in that file has in column
names
yes columnist yes yes editing them I
mean they're called the headers in you
know ACP and work parlance okay I'm
still confused this is the walk file and
normally in the case of so it has you
know you've got version URL etc etc this
is your date note thing
yeh in raw data let's just try it
you
I what is it doing is it is it it might
take a second oh okay
so raw data is not a date I'm not sure
for sure and I think probably yes I
might add just add a dimension but you
can see you know once the dataset loads
so you can see with with raw data that
work concurrent to and some of the other
you know work IP address or payload
digest all these random things
they aren't like required to be there
and so sometimes they're there sometimes
they're missing okay what's that there
wasn't Matt antennas so with raw data we
still attempt to perform interpretation
on values for example dates become date
objects whereas headers you know there's
no interpretation of the values it's
just the text and sort of okay it's a
terrible name for it if I might say so
because you've lent it to me for a while
here so Heather is a subset of raw
headers and lor heavens no no raw Oh raw
headers yeah why are they be well
headers it's because they're not payload
but you've included the payload here the
payload is separate from the headers but
it's in the headers table here right
okay um all right let's look at the
cases here so there's okay let's also
talk about how people are gonna use this
right so they've got a piece of a crawl
and so for example we'd like to feed it
into our text search system how would we
do it
so let's say I take this and I want to
feed it into the text search system so I
would for example take this thing here
and I would say somewhat confusingly I
would say of this percent nine all comma
payload right
okay so whatever these are okay so those
are HTTP responses when you probably
want to select just the responses so if
you do you know select yeah ahead it's
months yeah you just get the response
ones and then that those gives you all
the HT response objects and then each of
those you just want the bodies yep and
so then if you do
I think percent all
percent and then like you're only a
function on the data set where the
function is just getting the body of
each of those HIV responses then you
would feel our Knutson it's gonna be a
lot of that's eight hunt
how many 261 in this area it's gonna be
a lot of okay let's just take the first
five or something um does that make
sense
but by the way of rather a very in
felicitous display for the data set and
that would be worth reporting
let's see that this HTTP response
successfully got displayed but these did
not
could somebody read that because I think
the reason that happened is because the
the byte count of that HTTP response is
like very very little right because the
301 no no I get it I get it I get it's
an incorrect heuristic the heuristic is
saying because the underneath byte count
is big don't display it just display it
with ellipses but the fact is in this
particular case the displayed object
would actually be quite small because it
has a summary box right so the mistake
is that the data set display thing is
not aware of summary boxes makes sense I
see okay that would ultimately go to
Xavier I think um okay so then these
particular things we can say you know
body of each of these things if I'm not
mistaken and then we'll get welcome to
the archive okay fine
if you wanted you could also tribes I
mean I see two of those are images which
probably isn't very useful but you could
try importing the HTML strain and in a
while slow down the ask Jeeves crawler
maybe we should point out to Brewster
that that's a little bit out of date in
fact I might feel like sending a sending
mail to Brewster let me just copy that
out and I'll I'll put a little piece of
mail here
watch tends to crawl from I mean if the
crowd was done in 2008 well yeah okay
fair enough
when is the scroll from it must be much
more recent because a common pool hasn't
been going that long well this isn't
from the common crawl this is just an
example work file that was easy to
access oh I see I see okay so this is
completely around up then yeah so this
might have actually been from 2008 yes
okay fine
this was not a freshly cook thing where
the archive is out of date I did I did
sent you by email I did dub dub dub dub
wolf alikom warg file if you want to
just play around with the different sets
in no I don't need to I mean I I think I
understand this so so let's just
understand what the minimal code is to
do a text search based on this right has
somebody walked through that because
that's what you know that's a typical
case here and I'm wondering whether
there are some elements that we want um
okay so so I think as I said we only
want you don't want to describe all the
h3 responses you want to grab all the
HTML ones and then I assume because if
you're doing a text search you only care
about like you know the actual text
content of the HTML or not for example
HTML code right right in which case then
then you would need to run a further
import on HTML that was returned to get
just data just let me just move the text
content of that page right I mean the
fact is we could provide that you know
we could have a thing called web plain
text for example
as you mean as a column in the data set
or no I'm suggesting that an import
format will be Wayne web plaintext data
set that would be essentially what you
need for a for a you know to do it to
train it you know to text search which
would consist of the fields that were
the URL you know the plain text and
maybe some other information about dates
something like that mm-hmm
so in that case would would we filter
out elements that aren't there for
example unit yeah that's what we would
do if it says web plaintext data set
that's what we would do if we say web
image data set then we would get images
I mean these seem like the useful things
to be able to get from this walk file
okay yeah I mean we can look at so think
okay so it will be URL image um honestly
actually the image is okay
alt text you know text associated text
maybe and dates or we could just say all
the text since it's web stuff right I
mean that's what we're talking about
here alt text and we might I mean it
might be hard to get the alt text right
because it all searches defined on the
page where the image exists but well
does it have the referrer URL I mean in
some cases maybe not always because this
could just be any random web page that's
just if no I understand all the thing
but the the crawler might have been
pointed at the random web page but if
the caller was doing a hierarchical
crawl then as part of the assembly of
the walk file it might know where it
came from
yeah okay let's keep going onto the
other more basic things these these are
more you know let's let's talk about the
very basic ones so what you have here in
the basic case is what you claim is sort
of the minimal walk file thing which is
I mean that is a very irrelevant thing
here that version number I mean that
probably should be far to the right
if I'm not mistaken I mean that's the
walk version right um
I mean honestly that cruel date will
also be pretty irrelevant because that
crawl date is going to be pretty much a
typical walk file the crawl date will be
the same for everything yeah I mean you
can see right here like the the only
difference in these dates is just like a
few seconds because no I understand that
I understand it because it was a crawler
going through so to my mind
okay okay I know specific headers like
if you just want URL and content type
and payload is that easy to do
yeah we could say you know only take
specific columns well let's find out
what the import I mean like like saying
I want you know data but I don't you
know I just want specific columns or do
you just do that afterwards are there
there's the list of things that we've
got here okay
and if you do the one you did for for
raw data and look at the keys you'll see
a bunch of other random randomly made
things
that liquidator okay % 11 it looks like
not 12% well yeah
okay this is unbelievably full of
inconsistencies right
what is the
okay so the walk filename is the
original filename from which all these
things came is that right yep and so if
you're running across a large data set
which you know each file is like a
gigabyte or something you can identify
which part of the crawl based upon that
that file name
okay content length okay our payload
fine okay so walk date
what is walk type
so it's a work type is kind of like so
so you know the actual HTTP
request/response has a content type I'll
say you know utf-8 ISO latin-1 whatever
there's also a work type which says you
know this one that's a CD request this
is HD response this is metadata about
you know the [ __ ] how I'm running the
crawl this is you know a DNS request you
know various other it's kind of more of
them that a content type like what is
the paper what kind of thing is the
payload right I don't think that's a
relevant though to being to delivering
something that's useful here um okay
all right so let's make some suggestions
about what we want the I mean different
cases of what we want here so what we
already discussed here were these things
wherever we put them of um I just put
these here we go
okay
so that's your current list which I want
to
a bit of the import types right input
elements okay so let's talk about so I
think there's one the default probably
I don't think it's the right thing to
get rid of that walking walk type
because I think that you might very well
want to filter on that yes depending on
what those are and whether we curate
them what are the walk types that are
there yeah there's specific documented
ones it follows the mime type convention
but they have like some kind of mime
type extensions you know for example for
if you look at the HTTP request
it's like application slash HTTP
semicolon isn't that content type so so
content type is inside the so yeah it's
there's a hierarchy right so work type
says this is one element of the of the
crawl of the archive and that element
can have a content type or rather a work
type you know HP or HD response work
another data stuff like that and then
inside that you get to the payload and
that payload also has its own content
type of utf-8 of you know mime type of
this content type is then pulled out of
the payload as a as an informational
thing sort of exposed on the surface is
that right yes the content type is more
specific to the sorry okay work type
says what kind of object it is content
type says stuff like character encoding
that makes sense yeah I mean like it's
an HTTP response is what you mean by
walk type that right yes that is what I
mean yes okay so I mean what you're
proposing here what are we doing for
other formats that have these kinds of
composite what's a good comparable
format somebody who AM L okay let's look
at that one yeah I just put the format H
on the chair your chance in case you
want to look at that which format page
the work format what do you mean what I
mean you mean some kind of standard or
what yeah yeah yeah seem to be on the
shot oh you don't have to pull that one
just putting it there out there I mean
it there's lots of different types and
things in that specification that you
know that don't show up yet with that
one URL you if you've looked at just so
you're aware of that's there's different
versions and different you know okay you
know I would propose that we have a
thing called raw data set which returns
basically in the same order as the walk
thing the so that this would be the full
data set of raw walk fields does that
make sense yeah so so in that and so I
think mean and now get one that I have
is raw data except raw data is a list of
associations but it
okay broad dataset Joe okay question
about rod dataset should we perform
interpretation of the values ie turn
dates into date objects things like that
now I'm thinking
I think yes but I think we should have
another one that's called
something like this so Roth string data
set is then similar to what we have for
the headers element right now where you
don't perform interpretation of the
values that's what I'm thinking
and I mean I think you know I could
imagine one called data set
the
is some kind of subset of fields yep so
I think that's what I have is data right
that's like I think you have as data to
write that a set of raw walk fields with
values with it with values interpreted
oops values interpreted
do you think this is the right naming uh
no do you want to comment on this trails
or mutes I think that's good yeah that's
better than what we had for headers yes
definitely that was incomprehensible so
now the only question here so in this
case raw data set would be the names
that the wok system gives to each of
those fields other words we don't try to
cook those names yeah I'm saying and
that's important if you want to you know
if you need speed like if it's a big
file and you know the parsing may be
slow so well yeah but it's also just
people know what those yeah yeah you
know what you want right you know what
you want to you just extract us as
quickly as possible so now let me just
look at any other things I mean the web
plaintext data set seems highly useful
and you know I think a lot of the users
will actually want to just do things
like this it's no question the word
plaintext data set do we want mean that
has data set at the end whereas these
other ones have raw data set with dated
or oh wait nevermind nevermind it's
consistent sorry yeah I think some
reading backwards um okay
because I think those are the okay that
that's the most common form of cooking
is this now
we might also want something as simple
as images
that will just be a straight extract all
the image doesn't give me a list as
Wolfram language images right yeah yes
which is also what web image data set
should do I mean those are all Wolfram
language images right okay
so the one thing we have to talk about
now is what subset of fields is in the
thing called data set okay so what you
have right now is ah this right
well actually I'm totally confused
because oh I see my the first line was a
non-typical line
okay so the proposal would be it would
go URL
content-type can't we cook the
content-type do we have a representation
of that content-type as an entity if we
don't we probably should have I don't
think we have I think there will be a
good thing for us to do is to get mime
types because we have a bunch of that
stuff in connection with and we do have
format types as entities somewhere I'd
like to make that suggestion to Alan and
friends that we curate the mime types
and make them into entities Carla can
you make another day yes
let's see so then
you
where were we content type
do we want content length content size
is that useful yeah wouldn't sighs it
means rank thing it was the thing that
was a field called content link wasn't
it oh right so content like as a header
is just the number of bytes which I
don't think it's useful because you
don't know that information going into
the file but once you have it like
parsed like this you just do length of
everything so I don't think it's useful
okay I don't see that it should be
called payload given that it says
content-type why not just say content
here
that would be consistent yes okay
uhh
so date
and then maybe should we maybe name date
such that you know it's like because it
because it's the date that that thing
was requested not like the date returned
by that object should we maybe name that
like request date or crawl date or
something we don't know it's a cool
well you also don't know there's a
request fine so that's why we shouldn't
call it either of those okay hold on a
second
well actually the very obvious thing
would be content no content date is
ambiguous yeah because it's not the date
the content was that created or
something is at state maybe crawl date
no it we don't know it's a cool access
or creation date no it's access date is
best yeah access state makes sense
okay walk version and what is the record
ID so record ID is like kind of like the
UT ID for it it's used for example when
you have like I know for some reason
you're like looking at a 1 gigabyte file
and you decide to split it up into
smaller work elements you can mark those
as being for the same page with a
duplicated record ID okay somebody's I'm
trying to call it walk record ID if
that's there you shouldn't call it UUID
because you could have the same record
ID show up which takes the same time ok
we think we have a conclusion then here
is this everything that we were asking
about so this is Carla where would you
like me to put this so should I just
send this along let's just um not ILD
we're never gonna find it there do you
have a core software engineering folder
I don't think he does I do I should but
I also have import-export which seems
like a reasonable place to put this
ok um it wasn't under ILD I'm not sure
word it yeah I was under the alt section
um I can also mail this to you ok
anything else that we need to cover in
this discussion just so the kind of like
useful curated ones will just be plain
text and images where new text is not
HTML it's the actual text content oh
well ok the wait a minute this is I mean
we could have one called plain text that
is but the problem is that the plain
text really wants to be in a data set
that contains URL information because
not particularly useful to just say it
might be useful but it's much less
likely with images the typical thing is
these are all supposed to be images of
dogs or something coming from this
website and just give me all the images
I actually think
I mean it's going to get more
complicated where I mean the case that
is going to be interested in turist for
the images is what was the thing that
pointed to that image what was the
context of the image
yeah I mean I think theoretically that
information should be available because
there are for example like work metadata
things where it just says like out links
like after it performs the request it
computes what are all of the links from
this page to the next place and then it
will put that inside the work file and
then we'll actually go to those next
pages at least you know that's kind of
fun the comic comic role work files work
so ok another thing that would be
conceivable based on other kinds of
input formats is but I don't think it's
gonna be very useful for this is is
being able to ask specifically just for
access dates for example
hmm
so you say well no I'm saying that I
mean there will be I'm not sure whether
we want this images thing right now what
I'm saying is that I think that that
will be hard because I can return all of
the issues responses that were just of
an image you know image content type
that's that's simple as that makes sense
but you know how useful is that I guess
yeah I don't think that's particularly
useful let's not worry about that my
question is whether if you say import
blah blah blah you know blah blah blah
walk file um and then you just want the
access dates okay right I mean which of
these are was were naturally going to
want one might want access dates will
might want URLs those are two things
that seem actually useful
I feel like content right you just want
all the content but you could specify
this as a sub element and you know like
you say the main thing you want and then
either specify the list of you know
fields that you want I think that's not
how that's typically done okay fine
we don't have to do that as a top-level
thing that those are you know sub sub
elements yeah so you can say access
state yeah I think I think there's
examples in other import export formats
I kind of do it like yes I think so too
you can study that okay okay can we
declare victory on this particular item
yep and then we can if we do everything
here we can undo choice this one as well
yes in there just so quick question
about the example data for for work work
stuff should we I was just going to run
a a crawl of Wolfram calm and then
include that as you know the example
data egg will be huge well how do you go
for X let's use example data and just
gonna put examples on there let's let's
keep it small and you know I mean well I
think I need some diversity probably to
get interesting walk data I I think
that's sort of fraught with with
weirdness because you know Wolfram calm
will change over time
the example will not change the full
Wolfram website is millions of pages
let's create examples that are easy to
understand and you know not not trivial
but you know did have educational value
well maybe we can get an example what
would be a convenient thing I mean we
could just put an example like you know
example data dot Wolfram calm slash work
that just says you know some simple
contents and like yeah I mean I look I
think a cute example would be if there
is a copy somewhere on the out there on
the the archive or something of some
very early website perhaps even our very
early website you know perhaps a website
of ours from you know 1995 or something
which will be small kind of amusing and
doesn't need to change with time I can
look into we should have it and it
should be on the Internet Archive
probably as a walk file yeah right so
then we've got you know then we can just
have it from nature so to speak um we
can look internet you yeah I think
that's a good way to do it because that
way we don't have to worry about you
know it's an amusing example we don't
have to worry about it changing okay
okay
I'm sending this this to you guys and
and then let's wrap this meeting and I
think some of you are in the next
meeting about all of us great all right
so I think for those on the livestream
this is we will sign off from this
meeting and it will be back in a moment